in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sina Xadion for June 22, on which we commemorate the Holy Hieromater,
Osebius, Bishop of Samosata, during the reign of Emperor Constantius II, 337-360, who was
favorable to Aryanism, our Holy Father Osebius showed an ever-increasing zeal for the defense of the
true faith, as it had been proclaimed by the fathers at Nysia. He was chosen as Bishop of Samosata,
a town situated 140 miles to the east of Antioch on the north bank of the Euphrates, the chief
town of the province of Euphratania. His battles in support of Orthodoxy soon extended his
influence throughout Syria, so that when the Sea of Antioch became vacant, it was Osebius, who
influenced the election of St. Meletius. When Constantius discovered that Meletius, far from being
a sympathizer of the Aryan Party, was one of their most unyielding adversaries, he demanded to be given
the acts of the election, which had been confined to St. Osebius. The latter replied to the emperor's
envoys that he would be able to send them only after authorization from those who had signed them.
As they threatened to cut off his right hand, he extended his two wrists generously, saying,
I will not hand over the decree. During the brief reign of Julian the Apostate, in the year 360 through
363, who tried to restore paganism, the Holy Bishop dressed himself in soldier's garb and traveled
about Syria, Phoenicia and Palestine, encouraging the Christians to remain faithful in the face of
persecution and secretly ordaining priests and bishops. On Julian's death, he took part in a
council of 27 hierarchs who came together around St. Meletius to proclaim the doctrine of Nysia as
the rule of faith. It was thanks to his influence that St. Basil the Great was elected to the Sea of
Cessaria in Cappadocia in the year 370, and he was present at his consecration. From that time,
the two holy hierarchs linked in close friendship fought together for the unity of the Church.
St. Gregory the Theologian praised him as the column and foundation of the Church.
The light of the world, the rule of faith and the ambassador of truth. When valence came to power,
he showed himself a fanatical promoter of Aryanism. He renewed the persecution, had Meletius
banished to Armenia and deposed Eusebius sending him into exile in Thrace in the year 374,
where the saint was exposed to all the dangers of the war against the Goths.
When Eusebius received the sentence of exile from the emperor's envoys, he asked to be allowed to
wait until it was night, so that he might slip away from the town unnoticed, thus preventing a
revolt of the people on his behalf. As soon as the people realized that their bishops had been taken away,
they set out in boats along the Euphrates to search for him. When they found him,
Eusebius begged them to do nothing to have him released, and refused the presence they had brought
to comfort him in his misery. The Aryan Onomios was named in his place as bishop of Samosata,
but the people's disdain for him was so great that one day when he was bathing alone in the
public baths, not only did they refuse to accept his invitation to join him, but demanded that the
water of the baths be changed, for they did not wish to enter water soiled by the heresy of Aryanism.
In the face of such hostility, Eusebius resigned, but he was replaced by the fanatical Aryan
Lucius, who persecuted the Orthodox believers of the city. Valence finally died during his campaign
against the Goths in the year 378, and the Orthodox Emperor Gratian restored the church's freedom
and recalled the glorious confessors of the faith. St. Eusebius was thus able to return to his
spiritual flock, who received him with great rejoicing, and he immediately began to work to
fill the vacant seas with new shepherds. On the 22nd of June in 379, as he entered the town of
Dolika, now tell Deluk with the new bishop of the city, an Aryan woman threw a large brick at his
head, from the roof of a building. St. Eusebius was mortally struck down and overcome, but before he
died, he had the time to make them promise not to pursue the woman, and in imitation of the Lord,
and of St. Stephen, his last words were a prayer for his enemies. Through the prayers of our holy
fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.